phoenix will do you good paul version
back in the house
thanks for having me new york as [ __ ]
the new york times just hit [ __ ] which
is happening well clearly you dropped a
special you're acting a little different
now
look at the watch she's got it all yeah
no the special didn't drop it will drop
dropped no it will it will uh because i
got we got more offers no uh oh yeah
yeah so we're we're waiting we're it's
gonna be on one of the three major ones
but we're waiting i wanted to come and
announce it but what's it called it's
called nocturnal admissions yeah now let
me ask you this when you say three of
the major ones i'm thinking amazon
netflix and then one what's the other
one hbo
um are you allowed
is there it seems like a lot of people
are thinking about making the move to
youtube is is that something that you
thought about
yeah i mean there's always there's
always that option but i you know if
somebody wants it and they have
money you know not only money but like
you know like let's just say for example
you know netflix or like hulu or
somewhere like that and i'm not saying
that's who i'm talking to but if those
people have you know 50 million
subscribers and they're going to put it
on their home page
that that could kind of you know listen
i i have a ton of friends that have done
the youtube thing and the youtube thing
is great i've seen but you know 10 9
million as great as that seems i you
know netflix has 214. i've seen it both
ways i've seen go people on netflix and
like i didn't get anything to do yeah
like i got lost in the shuffle i've seen
some people go on youtube and i'll see
like shane gillis and mark norman they
blow up but i've seen some people go on
youtube and like dude i got 10 000 views
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the yeah you
know that's the way i think the
marketing is a big part of it i think
the clips is a really big part of it for
sure putting out clips having the clip
shared on the right social media time at
the right time
so yeah so but i'm i'm proud of the hour
and i think i think it needs to you know
when it gets seen hopefully so you're
releasing an hour not a half hour an
hour no hour it's about an hour and four
minutes you filmed it in new york yeah i
filmed it in new york i filmed it yeah
nice yeah i'm excited we're out in new
york did you film it i filmed this one
at levitt uh levity live
is that west lake west nile yep
i hear that's a great club it's yeah and
when they when you see how we dressed it
up it's it's like because they have the
reason why i picked i did my first one
in terrytown music hall right which is a
theater which is an old real like nice
theater yeah haunted uh what is that
what they call haunted is it terry town
oh yeah yeah there's a ghost in there
yeah i don't like [ __ ] like that sorry
that's definitely nice i know yeah sorry
this one they were like what do you want
to do was pandemic so i was like i want
to do it somewhere that i don't want to
do a small club i don't like that i
don't like when comic comics are going
yeah man i put a special out we put up
cameras in the [ __ ] improv it's like
like i'm not trying to but it's like
yeah it's like anybody could i it needs
to look like a special that's a problem
man everyone's putting out specials that
are like make it special yeah you know
what i mean like make it look special
like you got to make it look special
it's tough to make it i just feel like
the culture of specials is different now
it's basically an ad now to be like hey
i'm funny come buy tickets
filming long sets that's not like i grew
up like first a special to me was like a
[ __ ] special because that's back
there and 12 guys were doing that's what
i was gonna say there's about five or
six i'd even say yeah exactly like you
know eddie murphy you watch that the the
leather suit the lyrius you know yeah
you know carlin carlin would do one
every couple years now it's like people
are just like yeah i'm gonna do i think
i'm gonna make it a special it's like
what yeah i did a long shot last night
in brooklyn [ __ ] it i'll put it on
this guy's getting like [ __ ]
publicist
it's like you got a youtube clip
in brooklyn last night i think i'm gonna
get a publicist to call it my special
dude you can hear somebody eating pizza
in the front room
do you agree that there's just there's a
lot more options as far as like how you
can do it special which is good yes
you know what i mean and i think that i
think that now some people that are
really funny deserve that but i think
that i think that a real special will be
seen you'll know yeah you'll know like
that's when when you watch it you're
going to go oh this is a [ __ ] special
but also you're going to get your peers
to share it though too if it's good
they're going to blast it out for you
yeah yeah yeah no that makes a lot of
sense yeah yeah cream rises man if
somebody's doing if somebody's been in
the game for 15 20 years slugging it out
in clubs and they're murdering and then
they do a special on a grand stage and
it looks like a special that's gonna be
if somebody's you know seven years in
like oh my agent said maybe we should
call it that that's happening now yeah
there are and i'm not trying to talk
[ __ ] about anybody and i'll never knock
somebody's hustle if if somebody has a
good enough agent or marketer like hey
man make that a special and we're going
to get you sell you more tickets i'm
never going to knock that but the
product you'll see
yeah social media changed a lot of that
like yeah you before social media you
just had to rely on like two or three
venue avenues yeah and you had to be
that's why they were six or seven tough
it was tough man you had to get passed
by that and it cost so much money and
[ __ ] and there was one dude who would
always say yay or nate whether you got
to to montreal whether you got a [ __ ]
special it was unbelievable i don't
think that's the person no it was that
one guy dick that it's like
takes everything like the thanos of
comedy yeah yes dude i remember being
scared shitless about going into a
montreal audition and then and i
remember and they were like nice yeah
and then the next year he's funny but i
just want and it was just like and then
i'm seeing who they're taking and then
finally somebody said to me they go the
only way a dude like you was getting
montreal is if you [ __ ] blow them
away and you it's undeniable and then
they told me no
i did it and i had i both auditions and
the callback i took the lineup i did i
just were the new faces this was just
at the time and uh my manager called me
up called me in and he goes he goes uh
listen man he goes
montreal just called and said that they
they kind of waited and delayed to call
and this is 100
like almost verbatim what he said he
goes this he said it was a really tough
call because you deserve to be there but
they just can't they just they just
can't get you this year they can't get
you in they're going to get you just for
laughs and and um you know toronto one
year he said you're going to be you'll
you'll do chicago you will come to
montreal but right now so then i just
looked at him and i go should i just not
audition then because everybody saw what
i did so should i just not [ __ ] with you
anymore it is it's such a weird thing
and and then and then like um i would
say like a month later i was just
hanging out with my kids and it was like
july and they go hey man jfl said you
need to you need to be there go and i
went and i did all kinds of shows yeah
and then and it's the same thing uh when
i did you know a couple of these
platforms that were like yeah man he's
he's funny i just don't know and then
and then i was like we did the special i
was like i want everyone to see it
that's a weird thing oh yeah maybe we
could work something out now now it
doesn't matter it used to be when you
were like like 15 years ago when you did
montreal you only did it because the
idea was you get up in front of all
these quote-unquote producers right yeah
you come out with a with a developer
so for the longest time what i would do
is i i would i was just a young dude and
i would do a set and you would get a
[ __ ] they'd give you 250 grand
developmental just to be like we're
gonna wrench it it never happened for
any of us yeah and networks were like
hold on yeah it was great for a long
time but networks were like we're
putting all this money into this one
dude and then we're supposed to have
build a show around them but yeah that's
not how that works and that just sh that
[ __ ] stopped yeah completely for
everybody it was like now we're not
going to give development it's called
development well think about what you
were just saying like like they were
like yeah he's funny but we don't know
like think about just saying that like
they said insane
you know she was funny and that dude
we've been talking to for a couple years
and like where does he fit in but then
it was just like but all right like but
how about the jokes and how about the
set yeah how about the set cause i i am
here for a set but apparently you're not
they weren't not those places aren't
really there for the set right now
there's nothing agenda yeah there's an
agenda i asked you know what i was
actually i was actually walking around
montreal at jfl with the with robbie pra
and uh
who's now at netflix and i said i said
to him something like hey man can i ask
you a question i go when you when you
see somebody for an audition for
montreal
how long does it how long does it take
when do you know
and uh he's like well you know we
watched the whole set but he's like you
get a good indication like 90 seconds in
yeah just by the way somebody grabs a
microphone yeah yeah somebody grabs a
microphone puts it to the side and gets
to business or then you see somebody
like oh hey
remember the first [ __ ] that was the
[ __ ] out in the nbc last call
yeah so like i was like doing sets in
new york and like i thought i was like
like i had no idea what industry wanted
compared to
so i get on a [ __ ] bus and i go to
boston for a six a.m and there's just a
line around the block yeah there's like
comics there's a line of comics around
the block and like the producer had
clients walking the back door all makeup
like laughs like it was so [ __ ] fake
and i remember the two guys were just
sitting there like hey paul what's going
on and i do my jokes i was young like my
jokes were bad and i didn't and i also
didn't know i also didn't know what they
wanted so i did this i did this joke
about tattoos i was like yeah these
people get so stupid yeah these people
get like dragons and [ __ ] i want to see
like get something that means something
i want to see like an ethiopian kid with
like a loaf of bread on his all right
and i just go i just go they go uh
thanks paul we're that's good we're all
set i just this isn't nbc
you want to quote
like
stanford i started saying like [ __ ] that
wasn't even appropriate like i want to
see a broke person with like just like
you know a homeless guy with a [ __ ]
shed or whatever and like
and they were like yeah nah all right
paul and dude i just slowly i saw two
like dudes working the door like smiling
and i just walked back on a [ __ ] bus
and i sat on a bus before the darkest
[ __ ]
fox stand is hard [ __ ] i'm not ready
my wife how is it going i'm living my
dreams try it it's a dream
baby i'll be home i'm doing four hours
dude how about you ever do any health
road gigs or they're just hell i'm in
kansas i'm in [ __ ] kansas samford and
son that old thing and i'm in some best
western and it would
it was a it was a blizzard and so the
guy goes i can't pay you because
it's not my fault but apparently it's
not my phone it's not my mom we we've
canceled the the show and i think
tomorrow too so i'm not going to be able
to pay you i'm like
i had i had there was porn
it was when you could do porn on the tv
and i had there was a bible and i had
nothing else to read he had nothing and
i was like and all my friends are
crushing it at home like i'm friends
with like bradley cooper or will arnett
they're all making so much money
and i'm like hey guys i'm in the best
western i'm a late bloomer i'm also
older than all of them funny [ __ ]
[ __ ] i remember i traipsed everything
was closed i traipsed in the [ __ ]
snow to an ihop because i was starving
and i'm there and i'm cold and i'm
walking and this car full of these
mexican dudes
they were they were huddled in there and
they they go hey bro
what's up and i was like i think i'm
going to get [ __ ] killed or jumped
here and i was like i just looked at him
and i go uh police officer i'm just
going over there and they kind of
pulled out i feel like
first of all those are people in the
[ __ ] i sat in
these essays are on a trend
yeah
the guy goes hey bro what's up like i
was like this is going to be their
little churro
dude i was just staying in north
hollywood where we were shooting this
thing and i didn't realize north
hollywood's a little [ __ ] oh yeah
and like and i was just like i just went
they see them
why are you staying in north hollywood
i'm sure i was shooting a thing i was
doing acting on monday and tuesday you
know uh doing this small part in this
movie and they were like oh the set is
in north hollywood so my manager was
like i'll get i'll get you a hotel and i
was like and i'm like kind of like uh
i'm not gonna say i'm a prima donna but
like i'm not i don't i can't stay in
one time i went to i've been doing this
too long
i went to a best western once and i went
in the bathroom and it wasn't and i was
just like i'm not staying here now yeah
you know i'm not it comes to a point i'd
rather sleep in my car and i always look
at it like this if the owner and booker
wouldn't stay there then i'm not staying
no you know
yeah
you can't do that when you're on the
road all the time you can't stand dude i
got kids and [ __ ] i'm wiping down a best
western bathroom
[ __ ] depressing i [ __ ] get the hot
water and then i ta and i [ __ ] wipe
them like what am i cleaning this one
yeah right so you think they switch out
the sheets daddy no no they just make
get a [ __ ] one of those black lights
look it's just you'll see the murder
scene of comics
yeah i get [ __ ] nauseous
dude you know i think about all the time
last time around here when your dad sees
someone driving a toyota and he's like
oh
i gotta show you guys a picture i do it
all the time
dude there's a picture of my dad and me
holding me and i'm like in like oshkosh
overalls and i'm dirty my dad posed the
picture he's got like a white i have the
show you guys and he's we're in front of
his shotgun case right so he's got a
shotgun case he's got me then he's got
all his jewelry but i noticed his hand
he just had straight cash like a money
clip just to show he was like and i know
and i know my dad when when they were
taking the picture i know he was like oh
my
god
okay
hold on hold on he set that up for sure
wait don't take it yet let me in front
of the shot i can't tell you guys i
didn't tell you guys the the what my dad
did the geraldo rivera [ __ ] went last no
no
was not a gangster but no
as a matter of fact like educated and
would always tell my but he was 100
sicilian yeah i remember times people
approached my dad and they wanted my dad
to kind of work with them but my dad was
educated and would always tell us oh god
my dad is like a street kid but like but
like educated yeah
oh wait you're saying dudes would roll
up to him like yo come on no i remember
being in i remember being in an
apartment and some dude rolled up and uh
he was given like gave they always give
gifts so like my brother and me like
these disney that's how my dad said like
go in the other room and then my dad
would be like you know i remember one
time my dad was like yeah i think that
that dude does a lot of bad [ __ ] and i
was just really yeah but with
like hey let's get those [ __ ] micro
machines back man
dad's not going to do that
one was a picture of donald duck and one
was mickey mouse and my dad was just
like all right boys go inside and then
we just heard muttering and talking and
but my dad would always speak again like
you man you gotta you gotta be smart you
gotta but my dad was a streaker but my
dad is
unapologetically republican and and i
mean hard i love him and and i love him
and unapologetically patriotic this is a
true story i'm not saying this [ __ ] for
the i actually want to do it in my new
hour if i could figure out how to do it
so he calls me up and be hey paul i
don't my father would always ask
would ask a question but never listen to
the ending answer here yeah how you
doing good listen
everything's good he always everything's
good everything's good
listen he goes you know i'm watching
this [ __ ]
he goes i'm watching this you notice
geraldo rivera and i go yeah
i know this is recently no the dude this
is dude like my dad watches the news
he's so [ __ ] patriotic that somebody
so he goes yeah so
he goes yeah
so uh he's talking negatively about the
country it's really getting me excited
excellent and yeah it's getting me
excited and he goes but then he put on
an email address
i swear to god he put on an email
address and he said if any listeners
want to contribute or write in they
could write in he goes so i wrote
geraldo rivera a letter can i read it to
you
i swear to god
i go yeah yeah i know it's common yeah
yeah yeah he's gonna read it regardless
goes all right he goes
dear geraldo
you treasonous [ __ ]
i can't believe they gave an ugly [ __ ]
like you with that stupid mustache
national television time you piece of
[ __ ]
if i ever see you i'll kick the [ __ ] out
of you
you're not american go [ __ ] yourself
sincerely thomas j version
and then he weighs two feet and he goes
so what do you think
like i don't know dad maybe you should
have put esquire at the end of this
sincerely and here's the thing it wasn't
even he he it wasn't even a racist
comment because he is hispanic right
yeah he just said he had to say that of
course yeah he had to add that of course
he didn't say any negative thing no you
just let you know you remember when i'm
with your dad on this but you remember
when geraldo when we were like in the
middle of [ __ ] war in the middle east
yeah and he was like he you know he they
sent them out there as like you know the
field journalists and this [ __ ] dude
in the sand wrote our exact plans and
they had to sh that oh literally the
military like kicked them out like oh
you're out dude
you you you literally who didn't hurrah
hurray
because geraldo was like no he's not no
he's on fox for a reason he's like the
the counter like he's pretty cool no no
don't say something
no he's not no he's the opposite that's
why he's on fox he'll be the other voice
oh yeah he used to be oh
okay he'll be like a contrarian to
something it's like four against one
like i think they call it the five the
big five yeah it's four against one he
gets lit up really he was i didn't i
know that no he's liberal now yeah he
changed yeah but he was literally
drawing the sand our exact like plan and
war and it [ __ ] like
obviously
the opponent can't see what we're doing
oh he was on a plane the next day it was
like this is ridiculous i think that's
what my dad didn't like i think i think
because i didn't watch watch it or
whatever but i think he was saying
geraldo was doing something where he was
almost like telling our military plans
yeah yeah in a way and and and my dad
just yeah my dad also
do that
yeah yeah i don't play that either yeah
what are you doing dude
my dad got so mad about john kerry and
that that
swift boat thing remember that
controversy where he said he got injured
and he got a purple heart but it was
because he shot he shot a grenade
launcher
and he hurt his hand and he got a purple
there was a lot of shenanigans because
there were guys in his in his boat team
who were like that he didn't do that you
can't really lie about yourself
so it was really bad and my dad
was zero [ __ ] he had
yeah with four months as officer in
charge of the swift boat yeah my dad was
just i've never seen him like that kind
of [ __ ] he doesn't [ __ ] with was your
dad in the middle of that he was a
marine yeah and he was in the marines
when yeah yeah they don't dude
when me and my brother used to fight my
grandpa like you think i fought the
nazis so you two could fight
yeah we're six years old dude nazis what
are you talking about
my dad one time told me i never forgot
this my father i was defending clinton
for getting a blow job in the white
house i was defending him i was like
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like
everybody [ __ ] calm the [ __ ] now the
man's got all the [ __ ] to do his wife
and he don't [ __ ] obviously she's not
yeah she looks my father my father
that's all lizard he he literally my
father literally he goes he comes over
to me and he goes he's much taller i
mean he just looked down i'm never dad's
huge mother yeah his dad's bigger than
me and he's and he looked down and he
said he said
um there are things you don't understand
but let me let me try to
outline
why you're very mistaken here and i knew
when he does this with his nose he's
he's basically gone if i if you weren't
my son i'd probably punch in the face
but he'll he'll he'll he'll outline it
for you he'll romance your argument and
then outline yeah why you're wrong and
then i will exit this conversation here
that you're people to start that way
with his brain he said the oval office
is a sacred
place because it's where
the president of these united states
has the privilege to serve you
you get your dick sucked in there you do
that in there yeah and there are people
that fought and died for this country
and defended yeah this country and he
went through a whole patriotic litany
and i was you know i used to like a
terrorist i had to shut the [ __ ] up yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you hear it at that
level you're like oh it's not really a
[ __ ] it's kind of the this is
it's like you wouldn't catch up like a
blow job like in a bathroom during like
you're like a kid's christening
like conservatives and versus liberals
there's a personality trait it's really
[ __ ] interesting so with with a
liberal they'll say so
you find an american flag it's an old
flag in your attic it's been folded up
forever okay your house your bathroom is
[ __ ] dirty and you you forgot to buy
paper towels
the woman cuts it up
and uses it to clean the bathroom and
through the american flag this is now
hold on see what happens this is next
i'll fight you right now it's an
experiment
when you ask this really interesting
when you ask highly educated higher
educated people who are liberal if
that's bad they always say well it's not
hurting anybody so no it's not hold on
gets better
when you ask conservatives or you ask
people who have a personality that tends
to
value
tradition
uh value sanctity value like like uh
authority right values means it doesn't
eat soy oil
people like i think everybody in this
room whole milk not almond milk yeah
keep going all of us go what i don't
like that [ __ ] i didn't let you finish i
know are you [ __ ] me i know and they
then they do other things they do
another really [ __ ] up one
this is really cool they have liberals
and conservatives they go
brother and sister in the woods
nobody's around yeah
she's on birth control he uses a condom
they have sex hold on hold on wow hold
on brandon now keep your hands down they
have sex
no one sees it nothing happens is it
wrong now conservatives go dude
conservatives go yeah
it is because those two know it's wrong
liberals go well it's not hurting
anybody so there's a harm why do we have
to base it off these
terrible things
but it's like they're
that's those are the lines that so
liberals tend to be concerned about
fairness and care fair and care are you
cheating are you taken away from people
that are less franchised and are you
being fair
conservatives like fair and care but
they also they they also respect
authority they respect their sanctity so
would you take a [ __ ] on a on a
battlefield would you take a [ __ ] on a
battlefield where a bunch of americans
died liberals will say not hurting
anybody i'm i'm not doing that i'm not
doing that so it's it's a so now what
i'm saying i have like explosive
diarrhea that's exact dude yeah i was
like
my entire family's military military
through and through man like hardcore
but if you got diarrhea so i went hey
grandpa i know you of course i know you
killed some nazis dude of course i eat
[ __ ] chili last night bro of course
and i was i was on tour in germany i had
to [ __ ] on that boy would you get a
[ __ ] would you get a blow job on that
field where all the men died no see you
see what i mean but i come from a
different kind of club no it's your
personality bubba so they so they will
tell you right now they tell liberals
liberal politicians they go look
if you're a presidential candidate and
you're a democrat yeah you're not
getting republicans unless you
at least you understand how republicans
think which is that
they they tradition is [ __ ] important
you know you don't start talking about
tearing down statues because they go
hold on dude this is my country good or
bad yeah and and the you can't just to
start that you're going to just take
that down because you're trying to
re-write history right we we get very
very nervous about that [ __ ] americans
don't like that and and so a lot of real
americans yeah well a lot of a lot of
lit republic so when you have a liberal
politician trying to be a president and
they start talking about gender-neutral
bathrooms all of us go hey bro hey bro i
grew up with male female i don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about but
you're speaking a language that has no
relevance to my life see but also the
approval rating goes that's right what i
don't like is it's become and and this
is what really [ __ ] with me man is like
it's become hack
it's become a hacky thing to do
to say yo man soldiers are real heroes
give it up for the soldiers like they it
it's become a hack thing where comics
even joke about it and i'll be on stage
dude i'll be on stage and i'll see i'll
see
i'll be on stage and i'll see somebody
you know that's a soldier and i'll stop
the show and be like this and like i
don't give a [ __ ] if like you'll you'll
live literally have comics in new york
be like oh yeah what they do like give
it up for the troops and it's like no no
it's like first of all oh no dude yeah
dude i give troops free merch like do
not pay for anything dude dude
i love troops too troops are troops of
the ship you're these [ __ ] nerds
running a spiderman get the [ __ ] out of
here dude this guy's homeless
[ __ ] homeless guys this guy just took
bullets yeah that's his [ __ ] head for
you and he's [ __ ] crying in times
square because he's got nowhere to stay
he's talking to himself yeah and we call
him [ __ ] crazy so it's like it's like
that's that's a [ __ ] travesty you
know and i remember i was in san antonio
a soldier came up after the show
shrapnel scars burns and [ __ ] and he
goes uh don't never forget it's the most
gangster [ __ ] i ever [ __ ] because
they're on another another one yeah and
he just go i go thank you so much man
for coming shows no man thank you and i
was like no dude [ __ ] that i was like i
do this because of what what you guys do
yeah and he just goes he just goes well
you know man you just got to be willing
to die right now for the country he's
like i'm going to die right now for you
for his country and he was just like you
know are you ready to die for america
right now dude
people don't realize that these lines
that we live behind these walls we live
behind they you you they need a bubble
yeah but that's why i appreciate like
what south korea does where you have to
enlist in the army you know how much
better people would be if they were
forced into first of all you'd be in
another country so you'd probably get a
different perspective there's quite a
few countries that do that yeah but it's
just
he was in the nba he also older dude no
no no i'm talking about there was a nba
player who was like ufc they were gonna
no they were gonna go they were gonna go
to army they were gonna go to army in
upstate new york and and he was like nah
man i can't go visit future baby killers
he didn't want to that's [ __ ] he didn't
want to go visit cadets because of what
they might potentially do so that's this
that's under the same umbrella as oh
it's hacky to say give it up for the
troops oh what are they uneducated they
didn't go to [ __ ] high school so or
they dropped out of high school they
needed a weird stigma it's like no no
it's like it's like you're a [ __ ] who
could never [ __ ] do what they do you
could never leave your family go to boot
camp do that hard [ __ ] you're not
getting going you're not you're not
built like that so what you're going to
do is you're going to project whatever
well yeah
bill burr has the funniest [ __ ] [ __ ]
on that bill burr's like listen you're a
special forces guy you're a hero if
you're the guy who's in who's in front
of a judge and the judge goes you got
jail in the army what's it gonna be
take the army and you're the guy with
the [ __ ] flag
is that way
did you fix a jeep are you the guy who
is responsible for things oh yeah he
goes
try it now start it again
there is that element right yeah there
is there is i don't know what you're
saying though
there's a sanctity to the people that
defend the flag in this [ __ ] amazing
country that's what you're saying well
when when uh ukraine and russia popped
off uh you know
a bunch of you know twitter dummies were
on there like yeah you know i'm not i'm
not going to this wharf they want me to
fight something and then some guys some
parody account like some for some uh
he's like a general in the army goes oh
oh don't worry don't don't worry i think
you see he goes to trust me we're not uh
depending on america's freedom based off
you guys who can pass [ __ ] boot camp
like you're out of shape yeah you play
video games you play video games yeah
trust me we're not banking on you guys
yeah for the freedom of america yeah
you're where it's funny when people say
that call you guys yeah yeah
it's funny when people say they're like
oh i'm not i'm not going it's like i do
think i do not ask but i do think it's
patriotic as [ __ ] to know when we should
commit our troops and not and that's a
very important conversation to have you
know it's not just blind [ __ ] we're
going in you got to know whether or not
your leaders know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about they're doing well because
otherwise a lot of people die for no
[ __ ] reason on both sides
yeah yeah that's right but also
you know if putin does start to use
nuclear warfare you'll you'll see us get
involved because you can't have it
you're just that's going to be there you
just can't have that well that's where
he's headed because it's not
it's not going the way he planned well i
think there's no profit i think what's
going to happen is i think first of all
he's already really worried that he's
going to be taken out so he's already
put under house arrest several of his
inside staff there's a whole thing about
that
is that right yeah um and i i think that
somehow
i think putin is either going to go out
by his own people or he's going to come
to the realization that this there's not
a whole lot of profit and leveling i
think you're off i think i think i think
you're dealing with a madman who's at
the tail end of his career and he wants
to be
known and be
cemented but he was never acting like he
never acted like a madman he's very
[ __ ] tail end of his career like his
acting
he's morgan freeman you know what i'm
saying like i don't think he's never
just demonstrated being mad i think i
think he's going to be
pretty
embarrassed he's going to be embarrassed
and then he already nuclear warfare is
definitely an option and once you do
that that's that starts to really start
to progress i i agree i think
i lose sleep over it you know do you oh
yeah i don't think that's gonna don't
think that's on the table do you pray
because
i'm more worried about china backing
them than russia i don't know that china
will china doesn't benefit from this
china loves they make all our products
they love an intact marketplace yeah
they love a a purring economy they do
not need they have major problems china
people think that they're no no they're
major problems what i don't understand
is we're the because we're the baddest
[ __ ] we bring the pain right right
right by far sir by four we bring the
[ __ ] pain i don't understand why they
don't just keep it hush
send in like [ __ ] four oh we are seal
team six no we are yeah we are and just
you know what i mean like just double
down on the seal teams yeah that they do
the black water boys are over there yeah
not only that the biggest problem if you
can
you can look this up don't know if you
guys know this there's delta and there's
seal team and there's cia crown branch
and all these guys that [ __ ] show up
that are over there you just get you
just get killed it makes you proud to be
american well when you hear what they're
doing but
10 000 strong i don't know if newsweek
exposed this
after a three year investigation and we
have a 10 000 strong secret army
that nobody that do you know who they
are do you know their names do you know
what uniforms
are wild oh oh cyber warriors and uh
straight-up assassins men and women and
they don't wear uniforms and they're a
secret army yeah they're they're a
secret army they are not
and and that's a big
issue of contention though because it's
like they have a blank check who's
financing it where's the civilian
oversight oh and they're trained to the
gills and then also
this gave me [ __ ] chills the white
house correspondent they're talking
about you know russia hacking and
they're gonna infiltrate you know and
get into the banks and she goes you can
tell she's like she's so sick of dealing
she is no i i know i know it's like you
all we hear about is russian hackers the
best hackers are in america yeah we're
it's not even close it's not even a name
she just shut everybody down she was ham
if if we want to get serious about it
we'll get serious we're not worried
about it yeah you're like oh dude
[ __ ] you know what you're gonna say
you know what gave me the children that
[ __ ]
uh brandon and i were talking about it
it is dude
so basically they gotta get out of the
ocean
through the sand and they didn't see it
because they did go woke for a second
remember that and they showed russia's
military commercial competitors dude
this [ __ ] it's one of these dude this
[ __ ]
is it this one i don't i gotta see what
the stuff makes my dick hard dude dude
let's just shoot oh yeah get my hand
down my pants hold on oh yeah
i mean
all these dudes were under the in the
ocean and just [ __ ] just
like ghosts
like [ __ ] no nothing would be worse
than a [ __ ] woke navy seal
oh yo how gangster is that [ __ ] tell me
if you're a young kid you watch it
you're like oh that's so i gotta say
yeah and we're feeling really young you
don't get it and you're like mommy dad
why why didn't i stand as like because
they're so stealth yeah and then it's
like oh sign me there's like i want to
be stealthy
yeah
this guy
my buddy goes do you ever kill somebody
he's talking this delta guy he had the
greatest answer of all time he goes
my friend john goes do you ever kill
somebody he goes never stop to look
brother oh my god i want to do it
dude that's the most gangster show i'm
ready to die this minute never look ba i
mean dude oh dude are you ready
not at all dude
i was in afghanistan i got a late show a
bunch of dudes built like brendan but
they have long hair but they're just
like they all look different i'm like
why are those guys so weird i was like
yeah i was like well what's the nhl
hockey team doing here like what are
they what is this they were just giant
guys like him with just different
weaponry i was like what's all those
weapons and i'm talking to this
sergeant-at-arms they just walk by
they're not wearing any uniforms they're
not wearing any [ __ ] id and i go and
then they get in a cessna they got a new
cessna with no seats so i go
who the [ __ ] were they and the guy
guy goes that's the dark side bro oh oh
that's how he said [ __ ] gets me wrong i
know and i go well tell me more and he
goes i don't know when he goes i think
it might be the dreaded d oh i got the
dreaded d which is delta
whatever they are you don't want to be
on the receiver
my buddy who i do business with i won't
say his name because i want to add him
but uh he has as many he has more
tattoos than i do and he he was a
special forces guy like real special
force guy yeah he's a tattoo it says 67
with a bullet underneath it and then he
has x's at like six seven x's
oh
like we're at lunch like we were having
drinks oh i know what that oh is that
yeah what's that for and he goes
stuff
my dad
[Laughter]
there were times brandon and i were
talking about he went hard remember he
and i were talking this morning because
you know
he's he's he's got a lot of weaponry
like he can just kill you with his bare
hands right like look at him he's just
you know and he was saying he was like
there are people that just annoy the
[ __ ] out of you sometimes and you're
always trying
not to take i'm like their heads and
squeeze them dexter just go like i do a
pretty good job of it you do i do a good
job i could see you getting dropped out
of a helicopter into the ocean and just
coming out just [ __ ] lacing yeah he's
wasteful he's yeah you have that you
could tell that you have that like if
you had to you could do it right now yes
but there's also like a nice side but
you i decided it's 99.999 but you're
competitive you're competitive yeah and
if you had to do it it's there it's
there i did this i did this joke once
where i was just like these guys are
like live free or die and i was like
dude i'd stay captive like yeah you know
just slide rice under the door kick the
[ __ ] out of me
like i don't want to chill like yeah
like live free die like
i'll be a lot
skinnier say hey fellas can you cut back
on the rice i'm getting shredded man
just have an eating disorder i'm getting
trapped in a funny new fat like a p.o.w
diet
posting selfies just shredded in your
[ __ ] house chilling in my hood
[ __ ] in a hole you're weird
like dude look at this [ __ ] well that's
like my [ __ ] shredded man
my choice
who does whatever he does he's always
somewhere crazy and he was just in
ukraine and i go
i go what kind of weaponry do you use
because i don't have an m4 [ __ ] you
know it's like the
and i go what else he goes i'm going to
carry a handgun you know i go for close
quarters combat and he goes no not for
close quarters combat if i'm in
afghanistan i'm not getting taken
captive by those guys because it's
really bad yeah oh this just blow that
out put it in your mouth yeah that's it
i was like okay just to kill yourself i
feel like i'm charming enough
that's how funny is it i feel like i've
worked my way out i feel like i'm
charming enough and funny too to as
their time back dude dude come here dude
what are we doing me too like come on
let's do it i think about that
i think that [ __ ] talk about this
can i be honest with you i think about
that all the time like i make friends
everywhere yeah i feel like it'd be my
friend like come on
you're you're you're the biggest you're
not too much of a killer they'd be like
this guy's a killer
i'm with you guys but paul looks paul
you look way more i'm sorry to say this
out loud you look way more armenian or
arabic than you do italian no
i get it i get everything yeah i get
everything you could be arabic i get
everything dude if i get tanaka
hollywood you're mexican when i get
tanned yeah
i'm sicilian in greek
mediterranean
sometimes people say puerto rican but
most people most people say oh yeah
you said puerto rican i see that yeah
but armenian you're gonna be i mean it's
like it's not a bad thing i'm just
saying like you could be it was an actor
you could play an armenian gangster you
could play [ __ ] arabic yeah no one's
like what the hell no you could play a
lot of different things everything but
americans yeah yeah
yeah no but i i imagine like in black if
they [ __ ] like well like get down get
down i would definitely be like no dude
you don't understand like i'm [ __ ]
chill man i'm cool like coming up
i'm with you man bro i hold no value
you don't want me i tell dick jokes man
they don't want me let me give you five
minutes yeah yeah i'll give me five
minutes i'll do five minutes of my time
you don't laugh as [ __ ] you know what i
don't think
after your first joke you just start
that's happened that's happened in
history i always think about the trench
warfare in world war one where they were
just dying by the thousands it was the
worst [ __ ] in the world because you
couldn't get water there and they would
gas you and then the gas would settle in
the pools and it would rain so your
buddies would be dead and and everybody
be taking shits you'd be living in a
sewer
and they and it was so bad you could
smell the front line from two miles away
right yeah or five miles away but one
christmas eve there was a ceasefire
between the germans and the british
and they [ __ ] came out
and they exchanged gifts and they played
a soccer game before they killed each
other and no man's in no man's land they
played a soccer game and then loser gets
killed they all toasted each other most
they [ __ ] sang songs
and then they went back to the oranges
and they went back to war
it's a famous story that's amazing
that's all it took did we believe that
sort of no it's a song
not only how's that not a hollywood
movie
it was put in uh it was in a movie uh a
couple movies it's been in but it's one
of those things where you go these are
young man these young [ __ ] men who
started singing songs and decided let's
do a truce for new for
that's what my grandpa said he said when
he was fighting world war ii in germany
he'd see a nazi they'd be the same age
yeah and he said when you realize that
it's another human they're we're the
same age he isn't jesus yeah he was like
oh i don't hate him i hate what he
represents but we're the same person
fighting this [ __ ] war man yeah he's
like it's nuts b let me let's take a
little break from chat with paul verzi
and you know he's gonna be talking about
his dad because you know what dude i
want to talk nutrition and i want to
talk about how i get my
my phytonutrients bioflavonoids the
things you get from fruits and
vegetables
words right now i am i feel offended i'm
kind of i'm kind of a scientist but i
want somebody i want scientists to make
my stuff well thank god today's program
of the fire kit is brought to you by
athletic greens the health and wellness
company that makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really really simple
all right dude ag one by athletic greens
it's a superfood product it brings
convenient daily nutrition to everybody
everybody and it's everything you need
comprehensive man you got you can take a
bunch of pills capsules and everything
else what are we doing we have to drink
a tasty scoop of ag-1 75 vitamins
minerals whole food source ingredients
including multivitamin multi-mineral
probiotics green superfood blend and
more it's delicious dude it's fantastic
i put an eight ounce of water and your
boys off to the races
join the movement of athletes podcasters
comics moms dads step dads aunts your
gay uncle everybody loves it but i want
i want to i want a year free supply of
vitamin d and five free travel patterns
okay make that out yep with your first
purchase if you visit athleticgreens.com
fighter again all you got to do go to
athleticgreens.com fighter to take
control of your health and give a.g one
a try all right athletic greens.com
fighter
dude you know what investing could be
scary man like last month the stock and
crypto markets they got sucker punched
just by about everybody you dude the
crypto really fell hard man yep but you
know what not your boy here because i
got masterworks in my corner they help
normal guys like you me diversify their
portfolios with blue chip art from
masters like picasso monet basquat all
right
dude say what the all the ultra wealthy
have done it for centuries man when you
realize blue chip art prices outpace the
sp 500 by 164 percent for the last 25
years it just makes sense man
listen join over 330 000 members get
priority access to masterworks with this
unique link go to masterworks dot art
slash fighter that's masterworks dot art
slash
important disclosures that masterworks
dot io slash disclaimer that's
masterworks dot art slash fighter uh you
know what dude i need performance dude i
need performance i got a tough mudder
coming up april 9th 10 30 a.m
protein powder dude your boy's covering
covering all bases you got to take your
shroom tech sport
i need creatine i need protein powder
yes i need glutamine it's got you i know
they do they got you dude i know you got
to get your sleep sleep's very important
get your get your new mood get your
newman instant or get your melatonin
spray you guys you got to get your your
gut health right yes
sushi and i was dying and for a month i
didn't feel right took total gut health
i was gone it got my gut right dude it's
a fact and also if you're like me you're
a coffee connoisseur you want to wake up
in the morning how about a dark roast
from on it how about some whey protein
protein bars protein bites and if your
thick ass is a little too thick how
about some fitness gear at home we got
streaming fitness on-demand workouts we
got steel maces club mesas quad mesas
kettlebells up the gazoozies
we got battle rope sandbags go to
fighter on it.com fighter for ten
percent off the best supplements the
best training gear you can get for your
thick ass that's on it dot com slash
fighter 10 off you think it's nuts i did
um they do this thing like the day after
thanksgiving by my house uh where they
get 300 people go out and they divvy up
150 each and you go into all these acres
and it was like a snowstorm and you go
you go paintballing and it's a war and
it's like it's called like the the red
versus blue war and you go in there it
looks like the indians it was [ __ ]
i'm not even joking dude it was it was
nuts because the the team that you're
against we were on the red team i think
or no we were on the blue team and they
go the red team is acres away like like
a mile but they're coming and there's
all these structures you go behind you
can go in something and all of a sudden
dude you just start hearing yelling and
there were some guys that were
ex-military like some of the guys take
the [ __ ] to another yeah there's nothing
like you know like you're just getting
lit because i was a little bit covered
right
i had my son i had my son lucas with me
and a couple other dads in the
neighborhood that i know they had their
sons and i'm telling my son because this
[ __ ] hurts yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
and you could jack the gun up you can
get the the the paintball gun like you
know the way you could jack up a go-kart
to go faster yeah yeah yeah
co2 thing you could like make the [ __ ]
and uh it got it got like to the point
where i was like i mean i'm not gonna
obviously compare to war but as far as
if those are [ __ ] russians and you're
ukraine or what and you see that and
then all of a sudden it is like what
brendan sits another human right there
and you have a gun to kill them and they
have a gun to kill you there is a second
where you're like oh dude that's just a
dude like that's just a dude and i'm a
dude and it's it's a weird it's kind of
i say that a lot of people shoot over uh
the other guy's head they say in combat
there's not a lot of guys will shoot
over the other person's head and would
be weird imagine if you're watching a
guy who you see is dope at being a
soldier right you're just like get down
and he's [ __ ] doing everything and
you see him save a life and now he's
coming to you and it's your time there's
got to be something in you
if you're a good person
i'm about to take out a [ __ ] don't
see that that's why like uh i was
talking to my girl about it we're
watching i don't know zero dark 30 watch
about every every three weeks do we
sound like such [ __ ] if a real
military person would be like no they're
not no no no but there are so many
persons guys don't do well with this
stuff no but other guys
outside my girl she's like i feel like
because my family's in the military
she's like did you ever think about
going real time like yeah football
didn't work out like if i didn't get a
scholarship i'd [ __ ] went straight
military i want to be a navy seal she's
like you're too nice i was like yeah
you're right there's no way i could not
do it but but i feel like if i got had
the training and got the
the brainwashing you were saying on you
were saying when you did my podcast
diversity effect when you came on you
were saying that there was a thing that
when you were in the ufc you i don't
know if you remember you were saying
your corner knew
that like you needed to be you needed to
be looked at as like treated as a
competition they knew how to get you up
because you weren't the dude to just
break someone's head in and i i didn't
have anger yeah athlete versus you were
a competitive athlete versus somebody
that that is like an anger
and wants to yeah yeah and it costs me
like my coaching but even in training
like dude you got to get nasty like god
why though yeah
a lot of those guys that i've heard
other guys who are top tier like you
know special forces guys those those
seal team six guys a lot of those guys
first of all
number one it's it's not easy for them
after it's like they're killing people
it's not it's not lost on a lot of those
guys the guys they're killing might be
younger dudes who have been brainwashed
and don't have the weaponry whatever it
is it's not it's not like they don't pay
a price for that right but also the
other thing i've heard a lot of like uh
like high level tier one guy says a
large part of the job is knowing who not
to kill
in split seconds like like that's that's
where that's
that's where that friendly fight yeah
these guys these guys the real pros are
always talking about like i think tim
kennedy made a post about this he goes
the difference between me and the guys i
really admired was the guys that knew in
a split second who not to pull the
trigger on and when when the [ __ ] hits
the fan and everything's going that's
[ __ ] hard to do the hardest and how
crazy is it when you think about it it's
like being a good soldier
is like being a good actor a good comic
a good athlete those are the ones that
go to general yes because then you got
you then you like like the regular
soldiers are just like the players on
the team they show up you give them a
gun
but then you got somebody like like the
like the kobe bryant of yeah
he'll be like leading and making other
soldiers better whereas we need to be in
this position that's some gangster [ __ ]
you see you see that's so many levels
yeah it's crazy
yeah those guys are unbelievable you
know what i was thinking about like when
you were saying like that like uh if you
had to perform for your life i always
think about like in like the in like the
those times where you had to go in front
of a king and the king would just go
like i always think what my opener would
be oh my god dude your opener's it
because he's like all right he's eating
grapes and [ __ ] there's a jfl yeah
[Music]
doesn't do well and you see him kind of
stop with the grape and go like this and
then you're like no no so anyway yeah
yeah you try to pick it up
trying to transition yeah exactly yeah
all right so this room is crazy huh
bunch of guys yeah that's crazy all
these dudes man what's the deal with
that
y'all got grapes and feathers and [ __ ]
hell yeah i didn't hear is it just me
huh you just [ __ ]
you're like oh these chicks are [ __ ]
a king right like you start trying to
get on his knees
yeah you're waiting
behind the door and you just hear a fool
make me laugh
you're you're like two comics away are
you here kill him and you're like no
just dead and then and then you're like
they come over like you're next dude
like wait right now like yeah you're up
buddy bring in the fool i'm in a bad
mood
ten minutes you're up next time
i wish to be entertained and i'm in a
bad mood
don't like him if you're just here at
the middle of your joke but what's the
deal with airplanes
i don't like him i want him killed
please he just references something
that's so futuristic yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's an airplane no you're just here as
you're doing you're doing your pit and
then what the [ __ ] is the deal with
maggie i can answer mama put a pump on
my head and call me done
release the house
you just have like nervous comics like
online one guy's looking at his notes
it's on like a leaf i know yeah he's
like don't talk to me now yeah i'm
[ __ ] i'm getting and the king is all
lazy about it
i don't like him
it's making me sad
i don't know someone is busy
what would suck though is if the guy
that went before you crushed the king
oh my god this is the standing ovation
and then he brings them up now get up
here
next yeah
oh my [ __ ] god follow
did that happen did they really was that
[ __ ] like where you would go well
the idea was yeah what was it the fool
would come into the court suggestion
and you would wear a certain you know
you were there to make you wore that
[ __ ] there was there was that idea
right the tyrant if the title it was
like um tyrus would do there was a
[ __ ] ivan the terrible in in russia
he had this artist build him this insane
[ __ ] house like if you see it it's
got gems and it's like incredible and
that's the [ __ ] outfit you got to
wear yeah
just waiting to go
i've been terrible when the terrible
goes like this he goes you made he goes
i made you this incredible house and
ivan the terrible goes yeah i'm going to
take your eyes out now and he was like
but why and he goes because i don't want
you to be able to do this for anybody
else i'm like oh i'm not that's real
[ __ ] i'd go break my hand that was that
was in my eyes that's a true story brian
i would if i was the king i'd kill you
so fast because you have invisalign in
at your age i'm like
as soon as you're like
thank you guys for having me i'll go oh
no
out kill him i just got him trying to
fix his teeth i just got five my dentist
today and he goes like this he said
bubba you gotta listen
if you don't
if
you don't wear it 22 hours a day okay
what happens is you come back to us
after
15 trays which is 150 days and we go
you got to start from scratch because
all the teeth have to be moved in unison
wait what are you trying is you're
saying
22 hours before the next it's only
[ __ ] for the next uh
two and a half months no like does
something happen to your teeth to where
they go it's like a golfer at 67 like i
gotta fix my swing man you know it's
like what no it's over dude no no my
teeth are going to be very very
beautiful for what though hollywood this
is no because no right hear him out
right
right for your fair bite and stuff i
have problems that's what i'm saying you
have so you have a problem yeah my teeth
are cracking because they're they're
crowding and checking okay so that i'm
mixing and i've been putting it off yeah
but i've been putting this off for
30 years
i don't go to the dentist where he goes
hard on his recipients
at a certain time it's like [ __ ] you're
like don't you're 55.
it only gets worse it only gets worse
so now i'll do it uh two and a half
months i'll be fine yeah i had to get
two pulled back there that i gotta but
because they're not there yeah this it's
[ __ ] this up yep so i gotta get those
in and then your teeth are white as [ __ ]
yeah i use uh i sometimes i use strips
yeah i use i use the strips and then you
know that thing that glows you put like
something in my mind i never used it
i never used it so somebody was like be
careful and i was like what the [ __ ] is
that yeah yeah
like it makes it sensitive but the
strips aren't too bad listen don't
listen to me on teeth man i can't i
can't eat cake i go to dinner i haven't
had can i have a chocolate your teeth
are all cracked no they're not even
cracked i have four cavities in the back
i'm losing weight because i need sugar
so i'm like yeah don't think so are they
gonna are you gonna do something about
those cavities because eventually once i
get shredded enough that goes home
gravity's gonna [ __ ] you up it's not
like that
it's gonna have to get your heart root
canal yeah bad for your heart all that
stuff what's bad for your heart bacteria
yeah bacteria in the mouth you have when
you have something you have yeah
when you have a bad cavity when you have
a you know mine are small that's the
problem they're small and sensitive but
they're going to get bigger hey bro hey
bro what just take care of it yeah you
don't go you don't go to the dentist yet
i i went like uh four weeks tell me they
quoted [ __ ] nightmare tell me what
they quoted you oh that's because
they're gonna put veneers in it's 55
grand well you should go get those
cavities done no i should i'm just gonna
wait til i get down a certain way 55
grand 55 grand dude dentists get paid
dude
remember that chris rock joke he goes i
live in alpine new jersey he goes my
neighbors are he said jay-z
he said mary j blige he said some nba
player he goes and a dentist
yeah he paid for dentist dentist [ __ ]
dude dentists every day they're just
taking checks big
yeah oh it's never out of the stuff
and insurance dental is like the most
expensive you're lucky getting out with
five grand it's like if you have
significant work and they're like five
grand you're happy to oh yeah yeah
because i have 55k
it's a [ __ ] manual process too they
got to make it
for you i'll just buy a [ __ ] daytona
rolex to take the attention away from my
teeth how about that yeah how about that
[ __ ] you just like this [ __ ] great
i'm not grinding my teeth at night i've
always done that so my teeth were
[ __ ] cracked so yeah the enamel you
got your teeth when you sleep oh yeah oh
damn well i grind during the day because
the stress they said damn that's it
without even knowing you know it's not
during the night though i don't grind
during the night how do you know they
can tell i don't i might i'm a mouth
sleeper oh yeah yeah you sleep with my
mouth can you not breathe out of your
nose no so i have to i have to sleep did
you get it fixed though didn't you get
your nose fixed sure yeah sure
sure
that sucks okay you know i started
watching the change uh subjects here i
started watching uh tommy and uh uh
oh do you like hulu it's [ __ ] great
[ __ ] good you know i looked up last
night because you know tommy has a big
dick right barbed wire you know uh i
looked up how big his dick is nobody
really knows the actual size his dick's
all over he has such a nice decision
with celebrity decks i mean i mean it's
tommy lee it's it's it's it's his thing
it's like you know yeah they got a dick
yeah they they show they
i'm sure it's a
yeah it's prosthetic
the pam's boobs are prosthetics and then
his dick is a prosthetic as well but he
has a conversation with his dick to get
married to pam and the dick's like
talking it's very no
yeah it's like a [ __ ] kind of life
it was the only thing one small city
yeah he's on like xc or something like
that his dick like hey come on what
about this girl it's i was like oh this
is the worst part of the show but that's
okay i'll power through it
yeah he had a dick
and you know what you know what he's a
greek kid he's greek
i think i think tommy yeah he talks
about it he's greece right greeks are
working with people with a piece dude
you know what's heartbreaking
the kids got to get addicted
just the gay you got a dick to go to the
show that's a funny that'd be funny
greets have some dicks on him portion
his shoulders you know what then dude
how about something closer to my girl
should my girl know who tommy is right
born in mexico my girl has no idea i'm
like you know tell me a sex tape i was
like the first sex tape to go viral he
has a big dick he takes cover takes his
dick and honks the horn on the boat yeah
you're ready to go with the big dick
yeah they show you know the fake dick in
the show my girl i know jesus christ
that thing's you know she goes that'd be
bigger
oh boy
what
now hold on that thing is here's a
trivial question you have five seconds
to answer how long ago was that in years
what how long ago was that video 94 come
out how many years ago 94. no that was
in 94.
i'd say at least 20 years ago that came
out at 94. i had to be in junior high i
think i believe it was 95.
that was like one is when that video
came out it was 27 years ago man oh my
god almost 30 years ago oh i thought i
was in junior high tommy lee likes it
though he was like this show shows like
a beautiful story and it is a actual
pretty cool love story she said she they
should still be to get like do you see
that thing on howard stern's like what
she's like we probably should still be
together like that
i don't know when you watch that show
you're like this is chaos
there's like this intense love and
they're attracted to each other
yeah like she was like a hometown sweet
girl and he's pushing drugs on her and
he's this wild boy what episode are you
on three oh yeah it gets really good as
it progresses you kind of see like how
in love they actually are even though
he's kind of were they close in asia
were they further apart in age uh i know
he was a little older i don't know how
much seth rogen is great in it oh rogue
is amazing
yeah i worked with pam pam anderson and
uh she was so pretty dude in person she
wants people to look better in person
where you're like oh oh that's why
because you look like a dipped in gold
yeah yeah
she's so pretty for real you go and she
was older than when i was and then my
girl asked because you know she don't
know motley crue anything like that
she's like tommy had money like that i'm
like he sold 50 million right now
let's say they made he made a dollar a
record
look at her back oh it's stupid daddy
are you kidding me i [ __ ] with
yellowstone you guys watch that [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] yellowstone is the [ __ ]
yeah you [ __ ] block mine all that
goddamn time he blocked brian all the
time
yeah [ __ ] come on man
yellowstone i go to vacation with my
family in montana because of yellowstone
dude yellow specification
shot almost yeah
are you on 1883 though what do you mean
1883's that's the yellowstone it's on
paramount plus no bro it might be better
than yellowstone whoa it's [ __ ] good
and taylor did that one as well right
rider same director taylor sheridan
yeah he's the one on the horses and
she's here
yeah i get a little annoyed with him in
yellowstone because he's always like
showing off i rode horses all the
[ __ ] time you know he's doing the
horse shimmy and [ __ ] hey diddy get out
of the [ __ ] yeah they go a little
heavy with the horse tricks yeah it's
like 10 minutes
what the horse could do yeah
yeah they're stopping it's like but
they're [ __ ] violence in it and the
1883 might be better oh that's [ __ ]
good you saw every how the i one of the
greatest episodes of any show i've ever
seen ever was yellowstone episode one
season four that was i couldn't even
believe what i was watching violence
like after because because it ends
season three ends because
yes
episode uh season three ends where all
the main characters have an ordeal
and oh you think everybody's dead and
then and then episode one of season four
i'm like i can't even believe it's a
pretty violent show oh it's over dude
it'll go violent and then chill for a
while violent of [ __ ] machine gun
episode one of season four the episode
one season four and like rip and all
them come back you know it's like
[ __ ] dude this it's like [ __ ] it's
like cowboy mafia [ __ ]
like they're essentially a mafia it's
like somebody said it's like the
sopranos in like present day montana
with cowboys okay fighting overlapping
he's trying to protect his land and then
all these new builders are trying to
take over the land because
it's been family land for dude i'll
binge until four o'clock guys got to
calm down you you have to calm down
you're so you're so excited that you
keep interrupting and you're like
with his hands right now dude i wanted
to buy a big [ __ ] belt buckle when i
saw that [ __ ] like those big
i bought a cowboy hat champion yeah i
bought a [ __ ] i don't wear
i wear once a year in montana man to
look like real stuff
no the show will do that my buddy uh
kevin ryan he does are you garbage yeah
he goes dude i'm in i'm like two
episodes in he goes i'm thinking about
getting like go to zillow to get [ __ ]
a ranch like when you watch that [ __ ]
you're gonna start yeah
there was uh what's his name's great in
it too uh cole hauser oh rip your sound
rip dude you watch it or no no i just
know about how good of an actor is beth
you know she's english i couldn't
believe that when i said that the one
with the red hair the set of tits on her
she's reddish blonde hair she's like
[ __ ] oh who is she she's she's so
british
dude in that in that show dude she's
naked 24 7. she's got she's so gangster
oh and i'd heard she's such a woman man
she's from the united states she has got
a damn body those are natural by the way
she's older she's she's so good in this
and she's
a sexy
kevin costner's greater than it
costner's still kind of gangster man
yeah he is
yeah he is costner's still got a little
bit of that oh that's the guy tr uh
travis
yeah that's rip that's right that's
called houser yeah his character is just
his character is just
whatever whatever the boss needs
he just he's he's like
heavy he's like he's like yeah that's a
great way he's like luca i mean i'm more
confident but yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that's my favorite show that was that
was sammy the bull they would say like
gotti or something yeah it's like he
doesn't ask questions dirty
would be like can you take care of this
he'd be like
yeah i got it yeah kevin costello same
thing he's like hey take care of it then
he gets it done yeah that's that's his
his character
without a question because i brought him
in he brought him in as a kid so he's
like the big muscle like the [ __ ]
he's just like whatever needs he goes to
him and then he's he's in charge of the
ranch like the boys on the ranch yeah
cowboys and when they fight he goes hey
if you're going to fight somebody you
have to fight me you don't fight each
other you fight me you want to fight
somebody fight me call house he [ __ ]
everybody up yeah that's so funny
because like that's the character i hear
about the most even though i haven't
seen the show but his character is the
character if he's mad at you in the show
and he just started even his walk you're
like oh this dude's [ __ ] like he just
he'll walk up and just grab me and just
start beating the [ __ ] out of somebody
yeah it's crazy damn it's a good show
man my fave
all right jim what do you got all right
yeah but that tommy and pam was legit
dude it's so good and that actor that
plays tommy uh talked with sebastian
sebastian yeah you talked with him for
like months leading up to it learned to
play the drums everything
and now pamela has her own documentary
in the works of netflix yeah she won't
comment on the show yeah
she supports it but it doesn't paint her
in a bad light
at the very end yeah she probably wants
to save it yeah i would assume you know
i guess i'll watch that dog
uh where'd you go here we go
so colby covington and mozvidal got into
a fight at a miami like hot spot i guess
it's a restaurant
uh people are saying that they were
there and musket all saw colby and went
over while kobe was looking everybody
was outside the restaurant though uh
this is footage from outside it seemed
like they were inside somewhere i'm not
quite sure whether colby had broken his
tooth here's the thing mazda's facing a
felony charge now yeah it's not for you
but but but also like i like mazda but
also dude you had 25 minutes legally to
make money and beat them up and you you
got your ass beat by the way i'm talking
to our boy louis diaz because i'm going
to be down in my miami this weekend
which is i meant to tell you it's spring
break he goes he's going to do the worst
time he goes he goes dude they declared
a state of emergency yeah i was going to
tell you that because i played that last
year oh yeah they did yeah they lock it
down for what they uh they locked down
miami so so the fans go hold on oh south
beach miami's locked down so they don't
come out they don't come out
you couldn't be there a worse time is
that right i would never play spring
break again [ __ ] i'm gonna kill my agent
for this he doesn't know that yeah
well i guess it's really bad this year
so they i like mozzarella too but you
can't go up to somebody and just start
but they also just [ __ ] just [ __ ]
they just got a sucker punch
so that person told police after they
responded at 10 55 that he was attacked
by mazwell he was walking from the
restaurant according to the person
mazwell ran up from the left see he was
walking away from the restaurant ran up
from the left sucker punched him twice
one punch was to his mouth other than
his left eye during the attack the
person said moswalton you shouldn't have
been talking about my kids might as well
repeat a similar statement on social
media the person colby suffered a
fractured left tooth an abrasion does
left wrist no that's nothing that's yeah
bozodal corner of the person's account
was wearing a blue surgical mask and a
hoodie that covered his head like we
didn't know it was him uh he was able to
identify mozzarella he said because of
his trademark curly hair that flowed out
of his hoodie in addition to his voice
and the upper half of his face that's a
[ __ ] move yeah
you guys
also you're you're you're finally making
a lot of money you're a celebrity you're
a grown man miami you're 37 you're a
grown man in your hometown and you're
sitting but he also has he also has his
own fight organization out there too
it's like mazda's crushing it he tequila
i think like he's crushing what does he
do what are you doing but also bro yeah
you had 25 minutes
to legally [ __ ] up and get your ass
whooped that's right and now you're
gonna sucker punch him that's three
that's fair sucker punches i get don't
talk about family but don't suck at
punching a guy because he can't even
like when you come from the side it's
like like you said you had 25 minutes
yeah yeah i can understand it's like
years later he's talking [ __ ] about his
kids maybe but you guys just fought like
three actually you just fought like
three but don't say you're a
professional and you're jorge mosby doll
everything you have everything going for
you everything it's such a bad lecture
you might get charged with a felony oh
yeah well no but but i think what's
gonna help him out is kobe's a fighter
he's not gonna press charges i bet i bet
you kobe is in prison because he used to
be roommates
yeah i don't i i don't deep down he
probably wouldn't want to even though
it's like a rival sending him to jail
because that's jail that's like legit
time yeah well that's a felony yeah and
it's also though you know it's not just
jail time you if kobe wanted to sue the
[ __ ] out of him he could get a million
dollars out of him for that oh yeah
but yeah again with their history i
doubt kobe pressed his charges but it's
just dumb so stupid it's just immature
[ __ ] it is it's immature [ __ ] to just go
seriously it really is like the biggest
thing is they just fought for 25 minutes
inside the octagon yeah you did nothing
and also you get your ass you did it
professionally in front of the world for
25 minutes
yeah like got your ass beat for 25 yeah
he did he got he got beat up i had it
like was it i had four rounds to one was
that oh yeah yeah yeah but i just feel
like sucker punching too if you're gonna
like maz vidal would usually fight you
he'd be like let's go instead of coming
up behind you man i don't know
what else yeah it's weird
four men in florida were recently
arrested because they were caught
stealing gas they have a machine where
they can put a
device inside of the gas nozzle where it
control controls the flow of the gas and
they set it so they only get charged
about a penny to five cents
per gallon and so they were just
stealing loads and loads of gas taking
the contraption out and then moving on
and see the guy in l.a no well you set
up a van and the boat the bottom of the
van opens up and pulls up to where like
the the big semi trucks of gas put the
big hoses and fill it up so he would
pull up cover the opening open it up and
somehow figure out open up and then just
cipher gas out of it and then sell it to
people down the road like a dollar
remember you could pump gas and pay
after yeah
gas runs all that oh dude i felt like a
piece of [ __ ] i would do that one i'll
do this before i had no money i had no
money and i had no gas so i just pull up
and i'm just looking at the lady the
lady's like at the cash register i'm
just looking
and i just was like
oh my god i'm not gonna take too much
but i gotta get at least like 15 to get
out of here and i just did it and i just
kind of slowly
she starts walking i just [ __ ] ran
they they [ __ ] start running out and
i just peeled i had to i couldn't but
how insane was that that they you you
could not pay you dude what were they
thinking but also
you kind of deserve it yeah you could
just pump the guests and pay after
they're always gonna be one person a day
that's gonna do that at least oh my mom
would have me do it every week me and my
brother she's like okay i need gas we
don't have money i need guests so my
brother i was like 12 years old gangster
yeah yeah yeah my mom knows i'd pull up
in her camera and we just fill up
the same place it's like a block from
our house figure it out
is it is your podcast live no okay good
yo isn't that [ __ ] up though that like
we gotta be like just what you said
like just what you said before to what
you just said now it's like we we're in
a time
we're in a [ __ ] time dude where it's
like we go on a podcast and we're just
shooting a [ __ ] with our friends you
know you guys have been kind enough to
me to you know i consider you guys
friends you've been on my show yeah and
we're just sitting here shooting this
[ __ ] having a good time you know me and
you go back and you could sit there and
say some [ __ ] you could just say some
[ __ ] like yeah man my mom made me you
know or i was broke and i did and there
could be an article tomorrow about this
for sure
dude's family made him steal yeah that's
the type of parents he has and then all
of a sudden you're like yo my mom but we
didn't have a like you don't understand
who my mom is but like we were broke and
hungry so we would just go steal a block
of cheese i'll do you one better try
when me rogan brian and eddie bravo do
fight pains four hours we're hot we're
drinking you're just trying to figure
[ __ ] out dude you're talking people like
oh you said that's like dude i was high
and drunk yeah like that we were also
just talking we're talking it's like
it's it's like we're just hanging and
yeah we do obviously there's mics and
cameras but like fans want to listen to
people talk they want to listen to they
want to listen to you know somebody with
their friends shoot the [ __ ] and if
something comes out wild that's kind of
why people tune in because they're like
hey man you know what oh he was in a
mood and i know
if you know chappelle's in a mood he
could say this or if verzi's in a frisky
but he's going to say something like
that but that's what i want to hear but
it's not there's no malice in it yeah
but dude you can say something to a
woman
you can say something to a woman
like you might have read an article and
you say something about something and
then that would be an allegation that
she goes you know five years ago he said
this and there's no context it's it's
called a disturbing comment and that's
considered an allegation so nowadays you
can say anything and they can [ __ ]
bring it up whenever they want yeah and
if the right journalist or the wrong
journalist gets the past in the wrong
hands you're you're that's kind of what
you have to do deal with as a comic as a
podcaster we've all said a thousand
things that can be taken out of context
and i think you got to just be like [ __ ]
it this is the way we do this yeah you
literally had to yeah you literally had
but but you know yeah whatever you say
can be held against you as you get more
a fun time he's smart good no no i'm
sorry it's a fine line of being smart
because you do have to be you can't i
don't knucklehead if you're drinking and
smoking you're just going to be like oh
i'm drinking this and you're going to
say some [ __ ] that you know could get
you trouble that's stupid like that's
like you know what you're asking for
like yeah like you're going like it's
above and beyond and you're kind of
quoting an article you could be saying
anything right no no that's that's the
thing like that's and you may not have
said it because right
it's uh it's really wild
but yeah you're right i mean there are
some people just ignore like i know who
the [ __ ] i am and i know the type of
person i am but it's like if you know
you you know you're interested
it's like i don't know where your
special's going let's say it goes
i'm not saying it is let's say it goes
to netflix right so i was talking with
jeff dye about this so when you release
a special
you know you have your fan base and you
have people that know you and you're a
good person great dad we all know you in
here but when you release it let's say
you release on netflix or youtube yeah
well then you're putting out into the
world and they don't know you yeah and
then they get like oh do you hear what
he said about mexicans you hear what he
said about this his mom or his his wife
and it's like oh dude those were jokes
because you're opening yourself up to
the mass audience who it's going to piss
off a fuel you know it's going to be
yeah but you're playing home games
how about your home crowd knows exactly
who you are and they know
if you made a i don't know what your the
reference is but if if there's a
reference towards your wife like clearly
i love my wife but right clearly this is
a joke for the special well
yeah there there's there's a certain
there's a certain thing where it's like
thanks
when i'm on stage when i'm on stage
i all bets are off because if you're
dumb enough if you're dumb enough to not
understand that i'm making fun of this
for example right now we were hanging
out me giannis a couple of us were
hanging out and i was like dude you know
is there a joke with
these um asian people getting punched in
the face because of covet and everyone
goes no you can't do that you can't do
that [ __ ] and i go i go no there's a
joke okay so that night i uh i was at
the stand and i figured out a way to do
it asian people are laughing yeah okay
and because the joke is the lunacy of
some psychopath doing right and if
you're too [ __ ] dumb to understand
that it doesn't matter what we listen if
we start censoring ourselves as comics
we're really in trouble no no no no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no that's it
jeremy's raising that thing you sent me
from daley wire so daily wire jeremy's
raises is a new company they have this
hilarious ad what happened was they used
to be sponsored by harry's razors
harry's razors
heard
somebody from the daily
daily wires say a man is a man and a
woman is a woman there was somebody who
worked there said a man is a man and a
woman's a woman
okay so there that was considered
anti-trans so they said we're not going
to advertise on your platform
so there are there are these woe
corporations that are they're are
lockstep sanity but what happens is it
opens up it opens up you know the
marketplace for another [ __ ] company
who goes you guys don't want this there
are a lot of americans that will buy my
product so [ __ ] off and and you're
always going to have fans that come out
to see you because they love you and
they know the person you are and they
could tell from either encounters with
you or podcasts or anything that they
kind of know you know that's what i
think that's all that i do this this
last hour this new hour that i have
coming out like when you watch it you
know who i am where i come from top to
bottom and you sent to me it is oh
fantastic oh thank you man thank you no
this is this yeah you see
this is this is one where i'm just like
you just know who i am as a dude and if
i say something i say something but
there's no no one's hurting anybody and
i'm making jokes like you said if we
start
you want to do st do you want to do
stand up where everybody leaves and
everyone's happy i don't no no i don't
no oh dude my my special that drops end
of april you know i go hard in the paint
on my wife and her family super hard on
mexicans super yeah yeah they came to
the taping and i said hey babe you know
like these are jokes this is my
perspective and i wrote jokes out of it
but yeah so let your mom and your your
you know your family know like i'm i
don't actually hate them and she's like
and so i was so nervous i was like i was
saying comments can be a disaster they
were they were laughing the hardest i
could see them of course and they come
in the back and like that was great i'm
like you're not a fan like no yeah so
i'm like oh if they're not offended i
don't give a [ __ ] but yeah yeah yeah
dude i called for that yeah i called my
dad and i go dad listen i you know i
talk about you a little in the special
and you know i kind of talk about how
you uh those i don't good i don't give a
[ __ ] say it all like and here's just
yeah he's like because that's you know
he knows he's a unique character he
knows that he's unapologetic and some
people aren't gonna like him and he
knows that as i i'm a comic and i see
things that i want to talk about he's
totally it's like you said we think that
day because there is the thing where
it's like we chose to do this not them
yes in all the years i've been doing
this my wife one time because my wife is
like paul i know you respect me and you
respect the kids and i'll never
disrespect my wife for kids on stage as
a matter of fact i'll talk about them in
a praising way but sometimes i'll say
something about my wife but it's always
like what she really does how it annoys
me and it's fun-loving one time she was
like one time she goes that one is a
little do you and i'm like i kind of
felt it too yeah and it was and and
since i felt spirited that you yeah you
know if i feel it yeah you feel it too
then it's like you're not gonna do it as
i'm up there saying it i feel that she
would go uh he didn't need to 100 he
didn't need to say that yeah and then i
go you know what you're right only one
time and we know we know what we're
doing up there but i don't like people
that do what i don't like and i don't
like when comics do the thing where
they're gonna say some extra overly and
i don't like when comics and and you
know i won't obviously i won't mention
names i mean i will off air but uh i i
don't like when comics do that [ __ ]
about like talking about their kids in a
way where they're like you know they
talk about [ __ ] like that i don't like
when you talk about your kids in a gross
way
or like yeah or like even like you know
yeah like bathroom stuff or sex stuff
with kids and you're doing it you're
doing it because first of all
it's easy to get a reaction from and b
it's like your kids are gonna see that
yeah your son or daughter is gonna be
like one day going oh my dad was a comic
for how long oh let me look at his you
know what was it all oh he said that
about me when i was eight yeah that's
[ __ ] up and then you're like that's a
shitty thing man so it's like i always
look at it like that like that shock
value [ __ ] is like not
one thing you have to clear from the
in-laws
i don't give a [ __ ] people get upset i
don't give a [ __ ] doesn't matter if
they're cool with it then who else can
be mad at it yeah if they're not mad and
if they're laughing
there's nothing better than talking
about a group of people and making a
joke about them and they're laughing the
hardest and they get it yeah
that's the best right what else you got
jen uh actually
excuse me uh it's
1 41 right now it takes about 40 minutes
to get a burbank
uh what do you think five more minutes
and then give us one more then we'll get
him out of here what do you got what are
you shooting another movie are you big
thomas no no i got to do i'm actually uh
tom papa wanted me on the podcast oh
he's great hey what's up
yeah yeah i'm doing tell tom to send us
some [ __ ] bread
yes bro send everybody
i should probably try to get to uber
right yeah yeah yeah what the [ __ ] we're
not gonna do this is nuts yeah what is
what's even crazy how gangster is mike
tyson he doesn't he doesn't care this
guy pulls it he's challenging mike tyson
then pulls a gun everyone like kind of
sprints out tyson's just sitting there
how gay
you know brooklyn kid dude he crowned he
cried once going like he said like i
kind of can't wait to be to die
and he was just crying he said something
along those lines he's like yeah i just
don't want to be here anymore or
something like it's too much and i was
just like you could tell you meant dude
he's another dude man he's yeah
he's a good dude they have a video of it
yeah so this is in a hollywood it's a
comedy it's a bar that has like a
rooftop small rooftop comedy club on it
so there's a guy on stage doing his act
and some random guy just walks up to
mike tyson during the the comedians act
and starts talking to him and he goes
he goes something like i'm trying to
upgrade man i'm trying to fight he's out
of his mind fight you you just see mike
tyson was sitting there like dude get
the [ __ ] out of here he pulls up
step out of here i'm not playing with
you get up out of here bro come on hey i
don't give a [ __ ]
it's a guy in the black jacket on the
left
yeah so the tall guy is the host
come on
come on look this is easy you see he
pulled a gun right there
oh [ __ ] that guy did yeah i'm joking bro
mike
but what they didn't show before this is
he talks all that like world star has a
better video no
this is the the gun pulling part we have
the video world star has it where he's
talking [ __ ] in the beginning they kick
him off he pulls the gun out it's like
it's nuts tyson's telling him to come
over yeah tyson said come here oh tyson
gives him a hug
[Music]
gotta do ads
yeah here it is
says i'm trying to upgrade my status
wants to fight him
hey what the [ __ ] are you doing
crazy man i'm not playing with you get
up out of here
look at tyson
look at the [ __ ] king
looking they push him they pull out the
gun here
watch everyone go oh
[ __ ] i think that's darius on stage
[Music]
is it yeah there's been it and there's
when he hugs him dearest is hilarious
yeah all right
my thing is i can't believe these guys
are just letting them get away with that
nobody would tackle yeah like the fact
that he could have just hugged him and
shot him well i i agree i just think
it's really weird and no one not from
mike's team or the staff called the
police there's no report on it at all so
this guy just bounced but i'm sure the
cops are going to look for him now
yeah because he pulled the gun yeah yeah
yeah
i'm sure they're kind of licensed i know
paul let's get going he's got it that's
it well let us come back down when we
dropped that thank you thank you guys
for having me dude yeah i wanted to
announce it but uh i i i wanted to put
it in you're awesome oh i'll be it uh
i'll be at um no what's it called uh
yeah march 31st
rich ross april 2nd where you have to
stand with rich voss oh no that that's
just a stan that's just a showcase
lineup
the stand does their own
story it ends up being on my website by
them i don't know how i don't know
my date is uh comedy connections yeah
man so come out to that and then i'm
also going to be in san diego and being
tampa and all that so all right thank
you guys for having me i'll be in uh new
york uh may first and second yeah
schulte to stefano yeah hit me up hit me
up i'll be out there yeah uh
about times comes out to be sold out
seventh sold out show in a row at the
hollywood improv shop and friends dalia
kalanchapelle jeff dye myself the squad
is out the hollywood improv tonight but
the time you listen sold out uh chicago
is thurs this thursday friday saturday
chicago schomburg improv we're almost
sold out as well that's chicago illinois
schomburg improv march 24th to 26th
that's this thursday friday saturday
phoenix arizona chappelle lacey will
finally be there he's been avoiding us
phoenix stand up live april 14th through
the 16th and then the big boy moon tower
comedy festival is april 22nd through
the 23rd get your tickets right now and
that's it man take us at fatkz.com the
thick mudders april 9th 10 30 a.m sign
up using the code thick boy to run the
5k or 15k if you use the code think boy
you get 10 off your entry fee come get
some good brian where are you at um i'm
going to be in miami this weekend kids
great saturday sunday from spring break
uh tampa florida uh tap in broad april
15th 16th uh port charlotte florida
masonic theater april 21 to the 23rd i
got a lot of bubbles a lot of florida
right now
uh but uh also i'm shooting my special
brea tickets go on sale may
19th so come get you some brea i'm doing
my specials boom salt lake city i'll see
you uh april 8th and april 9th at wise
guys comedy club uh may 6th and 7th i'll
be in san diego at mike drop comedy club
and then may 12th one nighter in the
hometown phoenix stand up live
boom all right that's it paul love you
man thank you guys see you guys that's
great of course always